da ist bl ja kein ding junge wilde mich
verarschen alter war das beabsichtigt
von dir
ich bin in der luft ich hab gar nicht
sagen wie gar nicht gesehen das kann man
doch aufnahmen sehen ja was ihr noch die
sonne geguckt junge so unfair
ich habe alle meine chance für den
abgegeben
ganz ehrlich da kann man zwei anderen
kiste nebeneinander packen hatte ja
in ihm habe ich im stack alten müll
kanal woanders abladen kk buchen kann
man nicht mit mini um scherben sich
irgend welche items wünschen aber kaum
schenke so ab hier
das muss so sein zack und aktiv action
und schon bin ich hier auf sicheren
fußes mit flaschen beworfen
das älteste in werfe nein habe ich nicht
12 ganz damen geschenkt klaps auf den po
und den arbeiten auch jeweilige
prinzessin fantastisch dass so viel
scheiße im inventar das kann doch nicht
sein
und ich war nicht bei meiner mining das
kommt einfach so fast nichts sagen auch
wieder fleisch wieso habe ich hier drin
marvel sandstein krippe läuft alles gar
nicht ob ich in fleisch im inventar
traurig sowas
ich mag vielleicht kein bock auf light
rosen
also müssen wir wirklich perfekt alles
irgendwie so richtig schön weil ich es
herausbekommen ok gemeindegrund sind
hier kultiviert ohne perfekt fackeln
könnten
gemeinde prinzessin mit einer baldigen
ohne das sieht gut aus weil die drohne
mit einer kultivierten prinzessin oder
andersrum dann aber eine baldige drohne
mit einer so jetzt geht es wieder ab
solar baldige prinzessin mit baldiger
drohne weil die großen qualitäten ich
will das mal alles weil dich haben
gemeinde königin war weil die königin
weil die gewaltige war wieder perfekt
sie kommt dann wieder beschlossen aus
mehr als viele klassen und generator in
zwei laster sonst schlecht also über auf
einem chip linie schon die kleinen
bieter seien verluste wie die partikel
herumfliegen für die im visier kein
stein letzte folge vom netz sein letztes
letzte volle hatte ich mir noch 110
redstone und einmal isoliert ist ok
das kommt bei bisher in und ja vier kann
immer mal wieder fragen die folge ist
hier schon so ziemlich am ende ich mache
noch zwölf minuten
wie kommt's ich weiß nicht frage ist
benutze ich glasscheiben oder glas
glaube ich benutze einfach glasscheiben
diesen sex hier sexy er jungs vier
bergleute ist am start
ach so ich wollte meinem einige leute
besuchen die ganze zeit solarpanel was
passt was stone wafer was ist das denn
irgendwas gibt quasi fest auf dem boden
das könnte ich ein bisschen la la la
eigenschaften scheiße nur mist gemacht
die dann nur mist solcher letzten
solarpanel ja das bringt mir das jetzt
das macht energie am tag
ja und wie treibe ich das an in dem das
einfach draußen stellt war wo die sonne
scheint
natürlich muss das direkt an generate
abpacken am besten einfach verbinden mit
kopper cable kanzler über die rede
packen würde ich sogar empfehlen am
anfang erst noch nicht so guten kabel
sagt das läuft so jetzt von monster
solarpanel da muss ich trotzdem was rein
tun
er musste gar nicht es ist der general
hat keine energie was los ist nach
meinung der ist schon komplett nach
unten gegangen
klasse es hat mir alles gemeint für mich
wärst du dich okay wenn wir so ein
fünf-minuten-takt machen dann jetzt fünf
minuten cut wozu oder wann bild zu
machen
hier war ich würd sagen dass die letzte
folge bei mir bloß die hilfe oder wie
also nehmen dann wird passend vom
schneiden hier noch ein grad dann bin
ich durch ja okay also was zu denen ja
sobald du den fünf minuten müssen genug
ist exakt 211 man solar helmut stimmt
den wollte ich noch machen
wir brauchen auch noch ein solarpanel
noch als natürlich etwas wenig gesammelt
diesmal muss sagen ich ein bisschen
enttäuscht aber ich sag mal so was heißt
enttäuscht ich gebe nichts und er gibt
mir was 26 honig bal honig essen
interessant zu wissen aus gerne möchte
guckt was zu höheren sommers für
gegenstände sei froh dass ich links da
muss ich noch mal meine ich will nicht
mein schwert gezückt hatte was ist denn
was bringt der induction furness nummer
den deutschen fans ist der verbesserte
electric fairness dass wir eine lex
alles ist sie in ofen nur das über
energie läuft nicht über kohle
naja gut oder schneller dementsprechend
nicht unbedingt also der in der elektrik
furness nicht ist nur effizienter machen
und der macht aus einer kohle für
entertain items beispielsweise kann ich
den denn
theoretisch mit dem generator weil ich
habe es kein platz mehr direkt neben
generell da kann ich dir noch einfach
mit kupferkabel verbinden wenn ja mit
welcher form angucken ja warte ich jetzt
noch kurz die wii zu ende und so ich
muss hier noch fackel dann kurz setzen
aber dann bin ich soweit durch wahn ist
ja echt kacke aus so einfach nur so im
kasten wenig gebaut habt hier hab ich
noch sechs ist fast perfekt
dann lasse ich das ganze erstmal
natürlich auch würde ich sagen alles
schon mal weg dann mehrmals aber nicht
mehr auf dem court zu gucken wie er sich
abrackert zeigt das kann alles weg weg
weg und das hier kommt dahin und
pastorin margrit leute sowieso noch
ausreiche um ein jetpack anhalt sich
auch die ganzen sachen dran lassen
können hast du meinen laser tue ich
schon mal sicherheitshalber august
rental as du musst mir unbedingt die
larven auf einen dann natürlich nichts
mitgenommen ärgert sich dass schon
wieder so dass ich zu dir kommen so ich
würde nur mal einen drink war jetzt noch
einmal eine tür damit ich auch ihr
einkommen in meinem häuschen so daran
dementsprechend so so sieht es gerade
bei mir aus hier freunde
das magere ausmaß von 20 minuten
aufnehmen
120 minuten so ich kann darüber wieso
ist hier wieso ist hier so ein komischer
blog auch weil ich hier meine leitung
damals hatte 2 markiert so ich werfe
aber unterliegt die post nicht
ja ich komme
b
hall
hallo so passt ein solarpanel guck dir
das mal etwas an ihm klappen sollte er
kann man sich endlich auch einen
besseren job machen
generell ist falsch das klappte nicht
warum haspo bayreuth unterzeichnet das
müsste irgendwo einer kiste sein
alles klar so sagte der general
davos in der mitte sein dass die band
bot muss und damit die sein
die bread butter sich wohl noch mal kurz
ein solarpanel auf abzocke so wtf man
hat bei der renndistanz von 10 prozent
was den kaputtgeht ich bodyguards alter
ja das ist zufall da kann ich nichts für
ich habe die region vom altar ich saß
davor lange dran
frau gedeck neues ding was du machst mit
direkten neues und zwar so dass das ding
oben guckt hier und ein generator kann
ziemlich verwenden ist ein hast du kabel
ja doch habe ich kupferkabel hier drin
38 2 und 2
das ist es gibt nur ein' inputs signal
und das ist das hier
es ist nur ein input signal das heißt
wenn du jetzt ein generator nutzt
verschiedene hier dran setzen dann ist
er verbunden und dann da oben drauf ein
solarpanel okay ja das war sonst hätte
das alles bleibt ja ich gehe zurück und
fragte das neue das geht ganz schnell
ich muss mal dass du warst eins ist du
kannst ja schon was sagen was man nach
meinem block 3 also ich weiß du mich
sogar stopp nur advantest habe ich mich
vorsichtig an sonst brauchst du doch
glaube ich nur drei kohle dass drei glas
hamburger solar der kohle gas generator
habe ich ja electronics zeigt wollte
dadurch wird so ein kleines kann
manchmal kurz fertig sechs goldene kabel
162 redstone ich nutze wieder dein
extractor physik wir ziehen das passt
das solarpanel kaputt gemacht und so
viel energie wie du von mir schon gesagt
hast
na ja also ich finde einfach dass ich
zwanzig minuten an diesen scheiß sachen
zusammen fahren wind ja aber das ist
zufall das ist mit der ranch hat man die
bestmögliche also wenn du es mit der
spitzhacke ab und würde ist es so dass
bis zu 90 prozent kaputt macht und wenn
du es mit der ranch abbaus das ist so
dass es zu 90 prozent heile bleibt ich
glaube dass jetzt was ich mir machen
wäre das ein extrakt ab
3 gleich noch und drei kohle was haben
wir da eine coole weg von solarzellen
für den helm die nicht auf habe musste
ich mir neuen solarpanels kräften 9
ja weil das ein low voltage so einer wie
der wii neuen solarpanels auf einmal
erweiterten hellmann ja ja genau ist
schon low voltage nicht dennoch so jetzt
sollte es funktionieren weil du hast
links aber wie gesagt das obere ist er
im kopf erwarte ich komm mal kurz drüber
bei mir na ja ich hab das gar mit dem
sipri 47 kurz so was macht ihr da nicht
einfach mal so ein stein ziegltrum auf
dem weg und prozent blog fenster und
sowas ja mal eine fahne
er war hat das nur ein input signal das
ist von oben das heißt wenn später
weitere solarparks waren musste das
hochziehen müssen aber so ist egal
welcher egal welche energie kommt das
geht immer hier im unten hin das ist ein
signal an alle outputs mehr solarpanel
heißt mehr ladin richtig gut
warum passiert der gäste gleich tag
wasser tatsächlich wenn du auf das
unabhängig liegt dann müsst ihr diese
unter der kasten gelb leuchten und dann
ist das eine das tut er gleich
wahrscheinlich bringen kann
wir haben welches licht level haben wir
haben nicht level 7 8 steigt langsam
jetzt zunächst noch dunkel in hof ließ
nicht mehr will 0
daran sieht man ja nicht nicht level
wenn du auf f3 drückst du bei damovo um
steht da ist bl
ja kein ding junge wilde mich verarschen
alter war das beabsichtigt von dir
ich bin in der luft ich hab gar nicht
sagt wir gar nicht gesehen das kann man
noch aufnahmen sehen überzeugen ob sonne
geguckt junge ist weg meine kiste ist
weggesprengt wo ich meine kiste ich kann
das nicht mehr einsammeln
wo kommen wir her soll helfen ja sogar
mir her alter ich habe eigentlich toll
du hast die ganzen rucksack jetzt weißt
gar nicht mehr welches mainz ist aber
ich hab nur 45 momentan gehabt alter wo
sind die ganzen kisten hin
meine kids katze mir vielleicht kurz nah
und fern ist sponsor